so we'll continue with our union
analysis of the Lion King today we ended
at the point where remember Mufasa had
taken Simba up to the top of Pride Rock
and described to him the fact that his
kingdom essentially constituted
everything that the light touched and
you can think about that as the domain
of the roughly speaking of the great
father with the domain of the great
mother on the outside of that being
symbolically equivalent to the
underworld or to death or to nature all
of those things seem to be approximately
equally true and he forbade Simba from
going to investigate what was beyond the
confines of the light and in some sense
that's exactly what a tradition does for
you it because the tradition is
precisely what defines the domain of the
light and to be moral from the
perspective of the tradition it's akin
to playing a piagetian game but only
adhering to the rules you know how
Piaget described the fact that when kids
first master a game they learned they
learn how to act it out and then they
learn what the rules are and then they
regard the rules in some sense as sacred
you can't go outside the rules and then
later in moral development if they get
to that stage then they start to
recognize themselves also as formulators
of the rule or formulators of the game
and culture tells you don't go beyond
the rules that's the definition of
morality within the box of culture and
you don't go outside of that and so
that's why Mufasa plays that particular
role and it's wise because if you go
outside the domain of what you already
understand then it's dangerous out there
clearly it's dangerous out there but the
downside of that particular message and
this is perhaps this is the mythological
reason why Mufasa isn't as aware as he
could be of scar
you know his knowledge is bounded and
he's no I'm not aware enough of what
lies outside of that in this realm let's
say of death and destruction and so scar
is he is able to overcome his his
brother one you see this sort of thing
happening to people very frequently for
example who developed post-traumatic
stress disorder
and one of the things that's not as well
known about post-traumatic stress
disorder as might be known is a it
happens to you if you encounter an
experience that sort of blows out the
axioms of your knowledge system that's
one way of looking at it it's so
unexpected that you can't account for it
within the confines of this of the
system that you're using to interpret
the world that often happens to people
when they encounter something that's
truly malevolent and that can be within
them or it can be in the form of someone
else who is genuinely out to hurt them
they're often people who develop PTSD
are often but not always somewhat naive
and they're not aware of the full
catastrophe of the world that might be
one way of looking at it and then they
encounter someone who's truly out to
hurt them and they can detect that even
in in the way the person's face looks or
they encounter a part of them that's
much more malevolent than they had ever
imagined it could possibly be and then
they do something terrible and then they
don't know what to do about it
so delay or the the Canadian General
wrote a book called shake hands with the
devil and it was about what happened to
him in Rwanda when he was stationed
there as a UN warrior or a UN soldier
and I mean Dallaire was not naive but
what he encountered was truly malevolent
and it just blew him into pieces and and
that that's what happens and so there's
real utility and staying within the
bounded domain but the problem is is
that there may be information that's
outside of that domain that you
absolutely need to know and so part of
the problem with being alive is that you
have to continually determine how much
you're going to maintain your stability
and how much you're going to explore and
you have to explore because the stable
part of you gets outdated but if you
explore too much or too too unwisely
then you can encounter things that flip
you upside down it's actually one of the
problems with being high and trade
openness especially if you're also high
in neuroticism because if you're open
you're creative you're always looking
for for ideas that are outside of your
current systematic way of thinking but
if you're high in eroticism so you
parents a lot of anxiety and emotional
pain and that sort of thing you can
continually upset your own apple cart
now the other thing that you might want
to think about this is really useful as
far as I'm concerned is you might want
to think about this politically and
we've been doing a lot of work I'm gonna
have one of my graduate students
actually come and talk to you about the
work we've been doing on personality and
Paul and political belief so what
happens with political belief is that if
you're high in openness and low in
conscientiousness you tend to be a
liberal the openness being the
particularly important part of that and
if you're low in openness and high in
conscientiousness especially orderliness
you tend to be a conservative now it's
kind of strange because openness and
conscientiousness aren't very highly
correlated so it's not obvious why those
two traits would combine to determine
political belief and and the
relationship is actually quite strong
between temperament and political belief
if you measure political belief
comprehensively but it seems to me that
the fundamental distinction and this is
the political game at least along the
liberal conservative axis this boils
down to one thing it boils down to how
open borders should be compared to how
close they should be and you know you
can see that reflected for example in
the attractiveness of Trump to a large
part of the general population because
he's going to close the borders build a
wall and fortify the borders and
conservatives like that they like to
have borders between things stay tight
and they don't even care if it's state
borders or political borders or town
borders or ethnic borders or borders
between ideas or borders between sexual
identities conservatives like to have
things stay in the damn box where they
belong
partly because they're orderly and
partly because they're lone openness
they don't get any real they're not
interested in what happens if you free
up your conceptions all they see in that
is the probability of disorder whereas
liberals who are high in openness and
low and conscientiousness slash
orderliness they get a real charge out
of letting things out of the box so that
they can creatively interplay now the
issue is who's correct and the answer is
you don't know because the environment
underneath the political landscape moves
and so sometimes the right answer is
tighten up the borders and fortify and
sometimes the right answer is no no
loosen things up because everything's
good
to static and tight and we need more
information and the dialogue that occurs
in the political landscape with this is
why dialogue is so important is
fundamentally between these two opposing
views of borders and because you can't
say with certainty which one is right at
any given time an open dialogue has to
maintain itself so that the entire
political State can maneuver properly
along that moving line it's absolutely
crucial it's really really really useful
to know that people vote their damn
temperament it gets you it gives you
more of an understanding at least in
principle of your of those who sit on
the other side of you on the political
fence and there's been recent newspaper
articles quite interesting I tweeted a
couple of them about this company and UK
called Cambridge analytics and they're
using the damn big five they can extract
out big five information from your
Facebook Likes they've got a model of
every single person in the United States
big five personality and they help Trump
craft political messages right down to
the level of apartment buildings to
appeal to people based on their Big Five
temperament and that's all recent work
and so one of the things that's very
interesting is we are teaching computers
to understand us so fast you can't
believe it and we really do risk walking
into an electronic world where you will
only see what you want to see I mean
obviously the marketers are trying to do
that as fast as possible right they only
want to send you ads that you're going
to be interested in because it's
expensive and foolish to send you
anything that will annoy you or that
you'll ignore and so the marketers are
trying like mad to map who you are even
by watching your eyes they're trying to
figure out who you are so they can send
you the right information but the danger
is that that will happen say in the
domain of news and broader information
increasing this tendency for people to
be siloed in their exposure to the
external world it's a big sort of like
each of us is becoming a micro celebrity
surrounded by electronic sycophants who
do nothing but tell us exactly what we
want to hear it's a real problem
Karl Popper a famous philosopher science
said that one of the things that you
should do and this is akin to the PIA
jetty and view is you should always look
for information that contradicts your
cur
viewpoint now that's painful right
because who wants their axioms
contradicted it can take you apart but
it's the only way that you can ensure
that you're learning at the same time
that you're maintaining your stability
and that's another reason why it's
really necessary to engage in dialogue
with people that you do not agree with
because they're the ones who will tell
you things that you don't know it's crew
it's crucial importance in the
maintenance of your own stability the
worst thing that can happen to a person
know because there's many horrible
things that can happen to a person but
one of the worst things that can happen
is that you find yourself in a situation
where no one is offering you corrective
feedback anymore because you rely on the
corrective feedback provided by other
people to keep yourself sane to keep
moving in the ever-changing environment
and if you cut yourself off from that
feedback then well then you end up
static and shrinking it's really it's
really not good you get less and less
competent you get less and less
confident and the threats outside of you
loom larger and larger so that's all to
do with the you know the domain outside
the light see young would also say that
out in this domain that sort of beyond
what you understand that's also where
you encounter the archetypes of the
collective unconscious now that's a
really really complicated idea but what
he means by that is that if you're put
outside the domain of your competence
you're going to start to use fantasy to
organize your world so I can give you an
example of that so you you I presume
most of you are old enough to have a
conscious memory of when the Twin Towers
came crashing down and so everybody in
the days after that was wandering around
like they were in the days and the
reason they were in the days is because
well it wasn't exactly clear what fell
right there was the physical towers fell
but that was only a tiny bit of the
problem because those physical towers
were embedded in a network of meaning
like a very very sophisticated network
of meaning but also a political network
and an economic network and a military
network and like they're they're nodes
inside a very complex system and so when
they come crashing down you don't know
what's come crashing down right so
you're out there in the unknown and and
wondering what's going on and wandering
around in the days which is exactly what
happened to people and then what bush
did
George W was immediately turned that
into a good versus evil drama instantly
and that's an archetypal idea so that's
when he came up with the idea of the
axis of evil I think that was Iran North
Korea and I don't remember the other one
at the moment but but he yeah he
immediately turned the political
landscape into a good versus evil drama
and he said to everyone in the world
that they were either with him or
against him fundamentally and that was
the that was part of the retreating into
a I guess a more protected landscape
that's one of the ways that human beings
deal with the encounter with a traumatic
threat and so the reason you meet the
unconscious and even the collective
unconscious on the border of your
knowledge is because when you hit the
border of your knowledge you start to
use fantasy in order to bring the the
newest form of order out of the unknown
so that you can start to make sense out
of it and that's what artists always do
that's what they do and so from the
Union perspective people who are engaged
in creative art are the ones who are on
the perimeter of knowledge structures
and so what they're doing is taking the
absolute unknown which would be in
Rumsfeld terms they're unknown unknowns
and turning them into partially known
unknowns that's what an artist does and
and especially the more classical
artists who deal with mythological and
religious themes which was the case for
art right up until really until the late
20th century
they're they're using these mythological
ideas to sort of extend the domain of
human knowledge out beyond its current
parameters and so artists do that and
literary people do that and and
dramatists do that and they help us
extend our knowledge now that's where
open people live that's another way of
thinking about so think about it this
way so you're in a city you know what
and the city has parts of it that
degenerate and so you could think about
that as order degenerating into chaos
and then the open people who are
creative come along and they find places
in the city that have degenerated but
that still have interesting potential
right and then they move in there where
it's cheap to and they start producing
art they start producing galleries and
then the coffee shops move in and then
the thing starts to get civilized and
then of course the more
all conservative types move in those
would be the yuppies roughly speaking so
they're they're much more conservative
than the artists but they're still
liberal compared to the bulk of the
population and so the more daring people
move in after the artists have civilized
it and then after that you know then the
chain stores start to move in and soon
it's completely turned into Zellers or
something like that and then the artists
have to go somewhere else and find
another place on the boundary where they
can live and it's a fizzy elizacass much
as a mental boundary and so you because
you think each of those personality
traits there's five dimensions each of
them represent the possibility of
inhabiting a kind of niche right an
ecological niche so if you're an
extroverted person your niche is the
social environment if you're an
introverted person the niches I think
nature I don't know that for sure
because I've never figured out exactly
what introverts are adapted to but it's
not exactly the social world if you're
agreeable then your niches relationships
if you're disagreeable your niches
competition if you're conscientious your
niche is duty and effort and so and and
that those niches are partly social
because so much of our environment is
social but they're also partly natural
because our social being is nested
inside the natural world and so you can
think about the big five traits as
different kinds of adaptations to
different kinds of niches and that's the
niche that the open people the open
exploratory types occupy so that seems
to make a higher-order super factor
extraversion and openness called
plasticity as opposed to stability which
is conscientiousness agreeableness and
emotional stability and there's a play
off between those two things because the
stable people obviously are stable but
the plastic types of people are more
dynamic and they're they're more
concerned with transformation and in
order to get a system optimally stable
and dynamic you have to have a continual
interplay of those of those factors
because static doesn't work because
everything changes that's the problem
with conservatism and the problem with
liberalism fundamentally is yes
everything changes but you have to bring
forward some structures from the past so
it's very it's very very difficult to
get that balance correct so
all right so anyways out there in the
underworld in the place beyond your
current conceptualizations that's the
place of death and nature and it's
beyond the light and it's also the place
of Hell and that's what you see here and
what do you how do you conceptualize
that well one of the things you'll see
if you're interested in this sort of
thing if you ever go read the writings
of the Columbine killers the teens
they're very interesting they're very
much worth reading especially I think
it's Dylan Klebold who was the more
literate of the two but he tells you
exactly where he went after brooding and
brooding and brooding on his his
isolation and segregation from mankind
so he's out there beyond he's out there
in a chaotic domain and because he's
tortured by that his thoughts take an
unbelievably dark turn like it's
unimaginably dark if you're interested
in that sort of thing you could read
that there's another book you could read
called panzram PA and Zed ra m and it's
a fascinating book it's about this guy
who I think he raped 1200 men so that
sort of tells you what sort of guy he
was extraordinarily physically powerful
and brutal and malevolent and he was
kind of a juvenile delinquent type and
they put him in a reform school and he
was not well treated in that reform
school it's sort of like the worst of
the Canadian residential schools and
when he came out he was not a happy boy
and so he spent the rest of his life
trying to be as destructive as he could
possibly imagine and purely consciously
with malevolent intent and then and and
believe me he was pretty destructive he
kept track of the dollar value of all
the buildings he burned down he tried to
start a war between Britain and the
United States like he was all out for
all-out mayhem his dying words they're
gonna hang him he told the guy who was
going to hang him he said hurry up you
who's your bastard I could kill 12 men
in the time it takes you to hang me and
that's exactly the sort of person he was
and he made friends with this physician
in the in the prison who he thought was
like the first person who ever did
something nice for him gave him a dollar
for cigarettes if I remember correctly
and the physician encouraged him to
write his autobiography and so he did
and it's it's available and so if you
want a view because you know you you
always think of people you think well
people have good intentions you know
that you especially think that if you're
naive and agreeable so all of you who
are sitting there out there thinking
people have good intentions you're
probably high in agreeableness but
that's not always the case
people can have very dark motivations
that are fully conscious and very well
elaborated and panzram was know he was
smart and his book is very well written
and he tells you exactly why he thought
the way he thought and so it's a good
glimpse of exactly this sort of thing
where you can get to if you want to by
brooding on your specific misfortune you
know and his his basic credo was that
human beings were so reprehensible that
they should just be eliminated and
believe me that's what he was trying to
do and these people who do terrible
things like the Columbine shooters
that's exactly what for black of a
better word they're possessed by its
sheer malevolence and the Columbine kids
had a much more spectacular catastrophe
planned than the one that actually
occurred and they knew it was going to
be a full-blown media circus and lots of
these people who engage in those sorts
of mass murders they know about the
other mass murders and they're engaged
in a competition and the competition is
who can do the most brutal thing the
fastest something like that so you can't
just be thinking about people who've you
know who have good intentions but have
somehow gone wrong if you ever meet
someone who isn't like that and you
think that you're just a tree with ripe
fruit to be plucked so you don't want to
be in that situation you have to keep
your eyes open and so anyways that's
basically what's encapsulated in this
part of the story now the hyenas go
after the little lion obviously but they
managed to escape
it's very malevolent scene and Mufasa
shows up at the last minute to rescue
them so and you know that there's also a
mythological trope there which is that
if you go outside your domain of
confidence and you encounter something
you don't understand the first thing
that you're going to do is look to the
knowledge structures that you already
possess to explain it right and that's
the you could say from a symbolic
perspective that that's the
manifestation of the father as of course
that's what you're going to do and you
you know what's really interesting
- is because I've had a lot of clients
who've had PTSD and and without
exception every single one of them was
induced by one form of malevolence or
another they have to develop a very
sophisticated philosophy of good and
evil to get out of it because they have
a worldview in which those things don't
really exist there's no such thing as
pure malevolence well that's fine unless
you encounter it and then as soon as you
encounter it as soon as you encounter it
you won't know what to do and then you
won't be able to get on with your life
you'll do nothing but think about that
and think about it and think about it
and think about it'll disrupt your sleep
it'll put you into a permanent state of
preparation for action because the part
of your brain that's detected that which
in my estimation by the way is the same
part at least in part that detects
snakes it's the same damn circuit once
it's seen something like that it is not
gonna let you go till you figure it out
and that's basically what post-traumatic
stress disorder is and you know to some
degree each of you will have experienced
that maybe not all of you in here but
many of you and you can tell that so if
you go back and you think about your
past and you have any memory that's more
than about eighteen months old and when
you think about it it produces a fair
bit of negative emotion then that's like
a minute that's like a place where
there's a mini post-traumatic stress
problem and what's happened you remember
I showed you that hierarchy moving from
tiny motor actions all the way up to
high order abstractions well you can
imagine say you have good person at the
top and and you you kind of use that
that scenario to construe other people
people are basically good well then you
run into someone who is not good and
boom the whole bloody system comes
tumbling down because it's violated that
highest order axiom
so that's post-traumatic stress disorder
if something has violated an axiom
that's more differentiated you know
closer to the actual motor output not
quite so high in the abstraction chain
then all it does is wipe out that part
of the structure it doesn't wipe out the
whole thing and you can tell if you have
holes in your perceptual value structure
by checking to see if you have memories
that are still alive in a negative way
that are old enough so that they should
have been incorporated into your
personality and so one of the things you
can do
you're doing one of the exercises that's
on myself authoring site you guys do the
personality analysis but there's another
program there called the that's called
the past authoring where you write down
an autobiography and thinking through
these things that have happened to you
in your past that are negative is a good
way of making them go away and thinking
them through kind of means you have to
figure out what happened right and then
you sort of have to figure out how to
make it not happen again what you're
trying to derive is some kind of causal
analysis how is it that I was put into a
situation where I was made vulnerable
you know and that could be well because
you're only four and you couldn't
protect yourself and now it's time to
update that because you're a fully
functioning adult or there may be things
that you have to think through and
change in your own personality or
attitudes that you've been holding on to
since you were tiny I have this client
once and she came in and told me that
she had been sexually assaulted by her
older brother and she told me the story
and I kind of got the impression that
maybe she was like eight and he was like
17 or something like that and she was
about 27 when she came and talked to me
and then I found out by further
questioning that she was 4 and he was 6
and I thought she still had this story
in her head of her being tormented by
this older person right that's how she
told the story and what I told her was
well look another way of looking at this
is that you two were very badly
supervised children because I mean he
was 6 for God's sake you know he's a
little kid that doesn't mean that what
happened to her was any less traumatic
but but he wasn't 17 right if the story
was different than the one she had in
her head and you know by the time she
left after we had that conversation it
was clear that the way that she was
construing the experience had radically
shifted and it was very interesting
because you know you think of the past
as fixed but and it is in some sense but
the reason you remember the past isn't
to make an objectively accurate record
of the past it's so that you can use the
information in the past to prepare you
for the future and your mind won't leave
you alone unless that has happened so if
you've encountered something that's
negative and you don't know why and you
don't know what to do about it if that
have
again in the future then that will stay
with you and I think one of the things
that does too is it increases your
overall physiological load is actually
physiologists who've been talking about
this I can't remember the damn phrase
but you could imagine that your mind is
doing something like this all the time
it's it's it's it's got a record in some
sense of your autobiographical
experiences and what it's doing is
calculating how frequently you've been
successful versus unsuccessful and the
more frequently that you've been
successful the higher you are up on the
dominance hierarchy that's one
possibility so your serotonin levels go
up and you're calmer but also it's
reasonable to assume that the
environment is less dangerous right
because that's sort of what constitutes
danger you're somewhere in and you act
and and something you don't want to have
happen happens that's danger and so your
brain is always trying to figure out how
to calibrate how anxious you should be
and one of the things that does is by
sort of keeping track of your past
success failure ratio and so to the
degree that your past has been
characterized by will call them failures
that those are situations where you do
not get what you want then your your
body your brain puts your body on
constant alert because if everything
that you've done has resulted in
catastrophe
then you're somewhere insanely dangerous
and you should be like like a you know
like a prey animal that's ready to dart
in any direction and how much you should
be a prey animal is dependent on it's an
estimate partly your trait neuroticism
partly your your success as adjudicated
by other people right because they'll
pop you up the doorman its hierarchy if
you've been successful but also partly
on your record of failures and successes
in the past and so you can go back and
you can find out where you have holes in
your in the structure through which
you're viewing the world that's one way
of looking at it and you can sew those
things up and that's a very that's in
some sense that's what you're doing in
psychotherapy you know partly it's
exposure to things you're afraid of and
disgusted by and are likely to avoid
that's a huge chunk of it but if you go
back into your past and you start
talking those things through it's really
the same thing it's more abstracted so
Freud of course was always when
he was doing his free association
process with his clients he'd find that
if he just let them talk that their
speech would circle until it hit a place
like that where they were confused and
doubtful and then their speech would
sort of wander around that and and then
they'd have an emotional expression that
was a consequence of that he thought the
emotional expression was what was
curative it was cathartic in his terms
but later James Pennebaker upon whom
these writing exercises I described his
research it is based on that my read my
exercises are based on his research he
found that if you brought college
students into the to the lab and you had
them write for 15 minutes three times
over three days about the worst thing
that had ever happened to them or the
worst thing they ever did if I remember
correctly they got worse in the short
term but better in the long run for
example they went visited the doctor
less and markers of their physical
health improved and so I think the
reason for that is because what does
that called is called something load
just about it got it right from the
physiologist it doesn't matter
they got healthier as far as I can tell
because they basically calmed down once
they had gone through the negative
memory and sorted it out properly and
told a properly articulated story and
figured out how to deal with it then
their physiology calmed down and so then
they weren't as stressed they weren't
producing as much cortisol and so
cortisol suppresses your immune function
and so they were more likely to stay
healthy and so well so that's all very
much we're thinking about that's all in
the domain outside of the light that's
one way of thinking about it now of
course Simba and his and what's the
girl's name
mala yeah they're you know pretty cowed
about what has happened because they
sort of stumbled stupidly out into the
unknown they stumbled foolishly out into
the unknown and this actually highlights
another union archetype and that's the
archetype of the trickster and the
trickster is like the Joker in the
king's court and the trickster is
someone who will be or play the fool and
the thing about the fool is that the
fool is close to the truth because you
can't learn anything new unless you're
willing to be
fool right you know what that's like you
you know exactly what that's like your
chart you have to master a new skill but
you're avoiding it because you know that
you'll be bad at it when you first do it
and if you're perfectionistic you're
gonna say well I can't allow myself to
be bad at anything I can't allow myself
to be a fool and no wonder but the
problem is is when you try something new
you're always a fool and so unless
you're willing to be a fool you can't
learn anything new and that's also why
you can regarded the trickster as the
precursor to the Savior architect Lee
speaking is because you cannot do the
right thing unless you're willing to be
a fool first and that's really worth
knowing lots of times you guys are gonna
make a stage transition in your life and
you're gonna feel like an imposter when
you get a new job or when you get a
promotion or something like that you're
gonna feel like an imposter and you are
because what do you know when you make
that first transition right but it's
gonna make you embarrassed and it's
gonna make you ashamed and all of those
things but you have to understand that
you are a fool when you first try
something new but you're a worse fool if
you don't try it now that doesn't mean
you should you know make like you know
everything as soon as you're promoted or
you have some transition in status
that's that's foolish of the wrong sort
but to know that to know that you have
to be fallible in order to progress is
an unbelievably useful thing it can free
you up you know what I was talking to a
writer the other day about his process
for beginning writing he's written many
books he writes a very very very bad
first draft right and that's a good way
to think about things is throughout your
life you're gonna be doing that is
writing the next draft of you and it's
pretty bad to begin with but that's okay
because it isn't gonna get any better
unless you put yourself out into the
domain of the unknown to begin with and
you know you might you might it might go
badly I mean that's what happens here
anyways Mufasa has a chat with Simba and
you know tells him that he's he did what
he wasn't supposed to do although you
know even in that situation with fauces
discipline is paradoxical because
there's part of him because he's
reasonably wise that knows that breaking
the rules like that is actually
necessary
even though you still have to say play
by the damn rules you know you have to
leave that door open so that the rules
can be broken an appropriate amount so
he forgives him and and and peace is
made between them and then they're there
they involve themselves in sort of
gazing at the night sky and so the two
of them do that together and the night
sky is an interesting place you know
because that's where the absolute
unknown resides and one of the things
young wrote a lot about was astrology
strangely enough slash astronomy and one
of young contentions this is a very
interesting one was that because the
night sky was completely unknown people
could project their fantasies into it
and that's what they did without with
astrology so astrology is this
cumulative fantasy that's going on in
the in that roughly speaking in the deep
unconscious projected on to the sky and
so if you analyze old astrological
writings what you're really doing is
analyzing old fantasies and because of
that you could develop some insight into
the structure of the mind and so he did
the same thing with alchemy and his
later writings which are very very
difficult to understand but extremely
worthwhile ok so anyways back to the to
the hellish domain now I told you that
that domain that's outside of knowledge
you could think about that as the
underworld or you can think about it as
nature the negative element of nature in
particular and so I mentioned that one
element of that is hellish and that's
exactly what the movie explains next it
does exactly that we go back out to this
domain that scar the adversary or the
negative king that's another way of
looking at him this is his his the
domain over which he rules and so you
can see him there surrounded in fire
same ideas the you know as the hyenas
surrounded by fire earlier although this
is green fire and smoke which I think is
even worse and this is where the movie
starts to draw on essentially Nazi
symbolism at least the symbolism of
totalitarian states and you know you
think about you think about a
totalitarian state you think about the
Nazis and they're goose-stepping
what's happening is that every single
person in the military becomes an
identical unit right a unit they're all
uniform and they're all in some sense
imitating
The Dictator in in an absolutely perfect
way and so the dictator wants to impose
strict uniformity on the entire
population that's order order and one of
the things we've discovered that's
really interesting is that discussed
sensitivity is associated with
orderliness and that's associated with
conscientiousness and one of the things
about Hitler was that he was very
disgust sensitive and a lot of his
hatred for non-aryans so imagine inside
the aryan box it was all uniform outside
it was all parasites and predators and
so and that was a manifestation of
disgust not of fear it's a whole
different thing
and if you read Hitler's table talk
which is a collection of his spontaneous
dinner speeches from 1939 to 1940 - it's
a very interesting book you see that his
metaphor for the Aryan race was a body a
pure body
unof salted by parasites or predators
and that he was trying to erect a border
around it to keep all of that away
so it's an immunological disgust like
metaphor and there's some recent work
that was published in PLoS ONE about
three years ago showing that brilliant
study should have got much more
attention showing that if you went
around and looked and sampled political
attitudes in different countries or even
within the same country what you found
was that the higher the prevalence of
infectious diseases the higher the
probability of totalitarian political
attitudes at the local level and you can
imagine well what happens if there's
infectious diseases is you want to put
borders around everything you don't want
free movement between ideas or people
because that's partly how the disease
spreads you're going to have much more
strict sexual rules for example because
that's a great way for diseases to be
transmitted and before Hitler went on
his rampage against the non-aryans he'd
cleaned up all the factories and like he
went in there and fumigated them it was
part of the law he went on a public
health campaign to get rid of
tuberculosis and he got rid of the bugs
in the factories as well he used cyclone
B that's an insecticide and that's the
gas that he used in the gas chambers
eventually so first it was the bugs in
the rats and then it was people who were
then it was euthanasia that was the neck
move and forced you euthanasia and the
the rationale for that was compassion by
the way just so you all know it's it's
it's merciful to put these people who
are burdensome to themselves and their
families and the state who are living
second-rate lives its merciful to
euthanize them and that was a huge
campaign in Germany it was after that
that the more racial purifications began
and so that's the disgust thing that's
unbelievably important it's it's it's
because lots of times people think that
conservatives are more anxiety sensitive
than liberals and that's why they're
closed in terms of their ideas that
doesn't look right
first of all conservatives are less
neurotic than liberals although the
effect isn't that big so it doesn't look
and they actually are there they score
higher in measures of well-being the
most unhappy people are liberal men by
the way so but you know people are often
accused if they're conservative of being
fearful and that's why they you know
suppress other people's viewpoints but
that doesn't look right it's low
openness and high orderliness and that
looks like it's associated with disgust
and that looks like it's associated with
something called the extended immune
system which is the proclivity of people
to to keep themselves away from
potential sources of contamination it's
really terrifying because one of the
things people often said about Germany
was that you know it was a very
civilized country and yet it descended
into barbarity
but conscientiousness is a very good
predictor of long-term success and so
you could say well conscientious
societies are more civilized but they're
also more orderly and that makes them
more discussed sensitive and so what it
might have easily might have easily been
in Germany was that it was an excess of
civilization rather than its lack that
produced exactly these consequences and
that's a far more frightening
proposition and one that's I believe
much more likely to be true Hitler
bathed four times a day and he was also
an admirer of willpower so he could
stand like this for eight hours in the
back of a car and the thing about
conscientious people is they're very
willpower oriented and so if you're
unfortunate enough to be sick
chronically in the house of someone
who's conscientious
if it's a mental illness you're more
likely to relapse because the
conscientious person is going to be
judgmental and they're going to say to
you if you're schizophrenic they're
going to say well if you just organize
yourself and get up in the morning and
try a little harder
you could overcome this which is of
course true except you can't because
you're schizophrenic and so the pressure
put on you by the anger and the contempt
is going to increase the probability
that you'll relapse so orderly people
are very judgmental and you know
orderliness is very highly associated
with things like anorexia and the
anorexic is basically someone who's so
disgust sensitive that they become
unable to tolerate their own body and
they see it as a source of corruption
and imperfection which of course is
exactly right it is and it's very
difficult thing to maintain order around
so anyways so what happens out here in
this terrible domain where scar rules is
that things turn into a totalitarian
state you know and he's presented here
as as a Nazi like leader and see there's
another thing that's really interesting
this even deeper than this from a
mythological perspective I don't know if
I can even go into it well not really I
guess what I'll have to do is satisfy
myself with this observation there's
always been some antagonism for example
between the Catholic Church and
rationalism and everyone knows that it's
a very long-standing antagonism that
sort of runs its way through at least
the last thousand years or so of Western
civilization and the people who regarded
kaathal catholics as antithetical to
science
take the Catholics to task for that and
describing it as prejudicial and super
and superstitious and fair enough
but there's something else going on
there that's more important and that's
the observation and this is at a deep
level again the observation that
rationality has one big problem so it's
it can easily become arrogant and
believe in its own theories so if you're
smart and there's gonna be some of you
people who are like that to some of you
your primary the primary trait that
distinguishes you from other people over
the course of your whole life was that
you are more intelligent than most and
you may have staked your identity on
that and an over value
and rationality and the problem with
that is that you you make a theory of
the world and then you tend to assume
that it's 100% correct that's the
tendency to fall in love with your own
theories and that's what a totalitarian
does the totalitarian says here's the
damn theory and it's exactly right and
you're gonna act it out exactly and if
you don't well we've got some special
treats in mind for you and one of the
most terrible things that that I
encountered while reading about
totalitarianism and this was even more
true of the Soviet Union under Stalin
was that the true believers and and
there were many of them we're in a
terrible position because according to
their own doctrine they're already
involved in the process that was going
to bring utopia to mankind the problems
had already been solved but many of them
were still suffering terribly as
individuals but if you're a totalitarian
believer in Utopia your own suffering
becomes heretical right because your
suffering is an indication that the damn
theory isn't correct and so then you're
in a terrible position because you
either admit that the theory isn't
correct and fall apart because of that
and maybe face terrible punishment as
well or you have to separate yourself
from your own suffering and lie about it
fundamentally and of course that's
exactly what happened in places like the
Soviet Union where everyone lied about
everything all of the time to themselves
to their family members to their friends
the entire system was completely
permeated by lies and so you get this
terrible place that scars the ruler over
which is totalitarian and brutal and
murderous and resentful and deceitful
and arrogant all at the same time and
that's brought about so mmm-hmm the
columbine guys for example when they're
justifying their murderous nests and
their plans to shoot up the schools they
keep making reference to the fact that
people had slighted them for example you
know and insulted them and that they
were alienated they weren't bullied
exactly the way the press made it out I
don't know if they were bullied anymore
than people usually are in high school
but they took their alienation
personally and we
guarded that their isolation from common
humanity as indication of the pathology
of everything and then they went out to
destroy and that's exactly what this
sort of thing represents that's the
uniformity and you see he's got this
kind of vicious grin on his face which
is malicious and and pleased all at the
same time there's no fear in that
it'sit's quite quite the opposite and
there's another image of you know using
what's essentially imagery of Hell which
everyone understands strangely enough
and that associates him with the
crescent moon and the crescent moon is
well it's a symbol of darkness and and
the underworld fundamentally so all
right so anyway so that's we see the the
underworld we see that which bullet lies
beyond the light and in there we see a
fragment of that that's basically
hellish and all of that's incorporated
into the story and everyone understands
that when they see it even without I
would say the overt references to Nazism
okay so now scar has a plan he's going
to kill the king and he's going to do
that by putting what the King loves in
danger and so scar feigning sympathy has
enticed Simba down into this ravine and
scars minions are going to cause a
wildebeest stampede right so a mindless
stampede to to to put to put Simba in
danger and so that's what happens here
the Whale debate start to march into the
ravine and everyone is making a scar
tells Mufasa that Simba is down in that
ravine and entices him down there and so
they're all off running to see if they
can save Simba and then you see Mufasa
running in front of the wildebeest herd
trying to try to find his son and trying
to stay ahead of them the mad mob that's
put his son in danger and so he tries to
escape climbing up the Butte which is
almost a sheer cliff and when it gets to
the top mmm his brother is waiting for
him there and he asks him to pull him up
and scar basically before he
indicates that he's betraying him and
puts his claws into Moo fusses paws and
throws him off the cliff and so that's
that and it's a sad part of the story
it's a hard part that's very hard on
kids because the father has died and you
know it's a rare kid who won't cry about
that scene in particular where you see
Simba very upset and his father dying
now this is a hard part of the story to
interpret and I don't know if it's
because of my lack of ability to
interpret her because the story takes a
weird twist here but there-there is this
confusion in the story about whether
Simba is an innocent victim who set up
for the murder of his father or whether
he actually bears some guilt for it you
know and he's broken some rules and and
that and and so on so he's not exactly
placed in the position of innocence but
of course he's also been set up by scar
in any case scar tells him that it's his
fault pure and pure and that because of
that he's going to have to leave he's
gonna have to be banished beyond the
kingdom now you see this motif quite
quite frequently in heroes stories where
the hero has to be raised outside of the
kingdom that happens with King Arthur
for example and it happens with Harry
Potter right because Harry Potter is
raised by muggles instead of being
inside the Magic Kingdom so it's a very
common theme and partly what it means is
that it means two things one is that you
do grow up alienated from your culture
to some degree there's no way around
that because the culture doesn't match
you perfectly and it doesn't work for
you perfectly and it's old and it's kind
of corrupt and it alienates you as it's
shaping you and so you're going to
develop some separation from it and you
see that in intergenerational rhetoric
you know we're the new generation has
the proclivity to blame the previous
generation for everything that's wrong
with the current system and fair enough
you know because you do inherit
everything that's wrong of course you
also inherit everything that's going
well which is a good thing to also
notice but the idea is that you can't
help but be alienated from let's call it
the patriarchy for for lack of a better
word because it's got a tyrannical
element and because it's not matched
well to you so but then there's also
this other issue which is well maybe
you're not being successful by the terms
that are by the values that are
instantiated in the current system and
you might say well that's because the
system is set up in an unfair manner and
fair enough but it's also possibly
because you're just not very good at
acting out those values right so part of
the reason you get alienated from your
culture is because the culture is
corrupt but another part of the reason
is you're just not doing as well as you
could be you're not playing by the rules
properly and so you get alienated and
you're unsuccessful because of your own
inadequacies and so the movie plays both
of those it's obviously Simba is set up
but there is an intimation that he's not
entirely blameless as well anyways he's
very broken up about this and no wonder
it's also partly a story of the
emergence of adolescence because you
know when you're a child and you're
ensconced right inside the familial
framework then you sort of exist within
that system of rules like you would
under the piagetian scheme but when you
become an adolescent then there's much
more of a proclivity to break free and
to start breaking rules and so that's
also akin in some sense to the death of
the father and that's a necessary
developmental stage anyway scar comes
down into the ravine it's all foggy now
because that goes along with the sort of
murkiness of death and tells Simba that
it's his fault and that he's going to
have to leave he's going to have to
leave the kingdom of his father which
makes sense now his father's dead so how
are you gonna once your father has died
how are you going to stay around in his
kingdom so to speak so and then scar
tries to get these hyenas to go track
Simba down and kill him so and Zazu goes
back to tell all the rest of the Lions
that Mufasa is dead and that Simba has
disappeared and then scar takes over
Pride Rock and so what's happened now is
the malevolent element of the King has
obtained control over
state right and so this is the king the
wise King wasn't paying enough attention
that's one way of looking at it and so
the malevolent part of the state has now
got control this is a very very old idea
I've traced it back at least several
thousand years in its in its
representation in stories you can see it
in Egyptian mythology for example so the
idea is that as the social structure
builds in complexity it offers you the
protection of a functioning complex
system but it also becomes increasingly
likely to turn into a tyranny and
because it's more and more powerful the
fact of its potential for tyranny
becomes more and more of a danger and so
then the question is well what are the
factors that encourages it turning into
a tyranny and one factor would be the
wise part of it is not paying enough
attention to the malevolent part of it
and you could say that's true at the
state level it's also true at the
individual level right you have to watch
your own proclivity to upset yourself
and other people and and take that into
account and pay careful attention to it
because otherwise it can gain control
especially because you're gonna avoid
looking at it and one of the
characteristics of the wise King who
gets overthrown by the tyrant is that he
has an evil brother and he won't pay
enough attention to him he avoids he
doesn't look and so the the evil King
gets the upper hand and that's what's
happened here and so notice now he takes
possession of Pride Rock not in full
daylight right but at night so that ties
his rule into the rule of unconscious
processes and and malevolence
alright so Simba runs away from the
kingdom out into the desert now why is
that well you remember maybe you
remember and maybe you don't maybe don't
know it the story of Exodus when Moses
takes the Hebrews out of Egypt they end
up in a desert well why well it's
because when you leave Kingdom no matter
how ironical you still fall into
disorder you're out in a place that's
desert there's no civilization there you
know that's what happened to Iraq after
the Americans went in you know the the
Americans the neo-cons were all
convinced that the Iraqis would Oh
welcome
with open arms and there would be this
smooth transition to democracy same idea
and Libya it's like no that's not what
happens what happens is the state
devolves into a desert chaos and maybe
then you can make order but probably not
and so Simba has left the kingdom and
the first thing that happens is he damn
near dies in the desert and so you know
if you have an old belief system and
it's not working very well and you
abandon it well good for you because
you're out of the old belief system but
now you're nowhere one of the things
that happens to alcoholics for example
and and draw a draw other drug addicts
as well so imagine that you're trying to
stop drinking alright fine maybe you
have to undergo some medical treatment
so when you first stop you don't die of
seizures because that often happens to
people who are addicted to alcohol so
and then they get valium or something
like that from a doctor to see them
through the first bits of what do you
call it well of sobering-up and so they
get through it and then then maybe two
weeks later they're not physiologically
dependent on alcohol anymore
the same thing is true of cocaine but if
you take them back and you put them in
their environment say they go back out
of the treatment center back into the
normal world they start drinking or
using right away again and the reason
for that is that well let's say you've
been an alcoholic for 20 years okay
first of all that's all you do for
entertainment you drink and all your
friends are alcoholics right and so if
you're gonna stop drinking not only do
you have to rid yourself of the of the
physiological addiction but you have to
completely learn a new way of living
because what do you know you have to get
rid of all your friends because they're
all drunks pretty much or if they're not
there at least people who are
facilitating your drinking so you have
to build a whole new social network you
don't know how to amuse yourself because
of course the way you've done that is by
going to the bar sitting at home
drinking and so there's a huge hole in
your life you abandon the previous
pathological mode
a patient but that just leaves you with
nothing and then you have to rebuild
that thing from from from from scratch
it's extraordinarily difficult and
that's why so many people fail when
they're trying to overcome a major
addiction so alright so anyways
Simba's out there in the desert he's
left his family and the comforts of home
and he's he's discovered by these by
Pumbaa and who's a little rats named Tim
Timon
yes he's a meerkat right which are very
cool things and they discover him and
this is sort of his transition into
adolescence and he he kind of finds and
this is I would say more typical of the
male transition into adolescence because
females of course hit puberty so much
younger the males who aren't very
attractive when they're young like and
just starting to undergo puberty they're
not very attractive to females they tend
to clump together in in gangs and and
and manage the transition over what
could be seven years so and that's what
happens here is Simba joins this little
gang of you know these guys are alright
but you know they're a little on the
primordial side you might say you know
one of them is basically just a walking
gastrointestinal tract and the other one
is he's not so bad but he's like you
know a foot high really what good is he
and so he he's got some second-rate
companions out here past the desert but
he enters he's out of childhood now and
now he enters the adolescent world and
what happens here is that very quickly
in the film he goes from being a little
cub to a full full adolescence and
there's about a five minute transition
and so it's the next stage in his
development and now he's out there in
this paradise which is kind of strange
because adolescence really is no no
picnic but the idea here is that he
really doesn't have any responsibilities
right none and that is one thing about
adolescences and even the stage of life
that you guys are out is you have lots
to do but you're not really responsible
for anyone other than yourself and so
even though you might be quite burdened
with your current responsibilities it's
nothing compared to what it will be like
when you you know you have
responsibilities for four children for
example or for the people that are
working for you or or whatever
so anyways out here it's a kind of
of place as well and adolescence is like
that we've had high school students try
to do the future authoring program you
know where they have to think three to
five years down the road it's like
forget that they just can't do it and
I've watched them and what happens is
you you immediately become aware of just
how little high school students know
when they're like fifteen or sixteen
three to five years forget it
they don't have the world knowledge to
project themselves out that far in the
future not even close and so we've built
a high school version that helps them
design a better future three to six
months down the road and even that's
really pushing it but you know
adolescents are more impulsive and they
live more for the moment and there's
some utility in that I mean being
impulsive and living for the moment is
one of the things that gets you pregnant
as a teenager and that is certainly one
way that the species has managed to
propagate itself and so positive emotion
and impulsivity are very tightly linked
and so he's out there in this adolescent
delusional fantasy that might be one way
of thinking about it but more important
he's out there where he's in a domain
now where the impulses of the moment
basically take precedence and so and I
think they sing some song about yeah
Hakuna Matata right which basically
means do whatever you do whatever you
want and tomorrow will take care of
itself or something like that so it's
very impulsive and lacks all
responsibilities one of the things that
I would recommend to you if you want to
protect yourself from ideological
possession shall we say is that when you
hear people speak politically and they
don't say anything about your
responsibilities you should probably
stop listening to them because whenever
they're trying to offer you something if
it doesn't come along with an equivalent
cost there's something being hidden from
you and they're appealing to the part of
you that's well I would say at best
adolescent so alright so anyways he's
out there in his little adolescent
paradise and with his dopey chums and
back at at Pride Rock things are not
good right Skaar who's arrogant and
refuses to learn and who will not
establish a reasonable relationship with
the females all he does is tyrannize
over them he ends up ruling over a
completely barren landscape and that's
really what happens in totalitarian
states and we also know quite
interestingly is that one of the best
predictors of economic development in a
state is the degree to which they extend
rights to women it's one of the best
predictors and I would say well if
you're going to terrorize your own women
you're gonna Tarin eyes everything
you're gonna Terran eyes ideas you're
gonna Terran eyes structures like if you
have to enslave your own women you're
you've del adapted a pretty damn
pathological view of the world and the
probability that that narrow constrained
restricted viewpoint is going to pay off
for you economically is extraordinarily
low so anyways Skaar it's like what
happened in the Soviet Union no part of
the reason it collapsed by 1989 is that
it just could not move any farther it
was like this really complicated motor
that was worn completely out that no one
had ever taken care of and it's just
ground to a halt
it just stopped working because it
because it didn't work and so if your
totalitarian and you won't update your
system and adjust it then it wears out
and grinds to a halt and everything
becomes unproductive no it's it's not
easy to figure out what makes a society
productive because you might say well
it's Natural Resources or something like
that first of all natural resources are
very often a curse to a country because
they produce corruption they call that
the Dutch disease there's a reason for
that
you can look it up but natural resources
in and of themselves are by no means
sufficient to guarantee the well-being
of a country Japan has virtually no
natural resources at all and it's really
rich and one of the prime natural
resources actually seems maybe there's
two one is honesty another is trust and
if you can set up a society where people
are roughly honest which means they do
what they say they're going to do and
where the default bargaining position on
both sides is trust then the probability
that that culture will become wealthy is
very very high so and a functional legal
system is also a natural resource of
tremendous tremendous value you know
it's partly why people in China for
example wealthy people in China are
dumping their money into the real estate
market in North America like mad because
one of the things you do know if you buy
real estate in North America is you
actually own it it's still gonna be
yours 20 years in the future 30 years in
the future there's no doubt about that
and so that fact of ownership is
embedded in the functioning legal system
and that's what gives those sorts of
properties crazy value you know much to
the much to the problematic situation
for all of you people who are at some
point most of you are gonna try to buy
property in Toronto and that's really
going to be entertaining so now look the
the other thing about scars he's got the
little bird locked up right that's the
vision of the king well he doesn't want
to know anything he already knows
everything so why does he need this
stupid bird flying around telling him
what's going on
the last thing he wants to know is
what's going on yeah Stalin I mean
God he gave that guy bad news or good
news he was going to have you killed
it kept the bad news to a minimum and
that's a real problem right because if
you torture people who bring you bad
news then you're never going to learn
anything well you don't have to if you
already know everything anyways and so
that's the situation here well his
little minions the hyenas are getting
pretty unhappy because they haven't had
anything to eat and the reason for that
is they've just stripped the landscape
bare right I mean and I read at the
demise of the Soviet Union that
something like 10 to 15 percent of the
entire land mass of the Soviet Union had
been rendered permanently uninhabitable
by industrial pollution so you know that
I don't remember if that included
Chernobyl you know where that terrible
nuclear accident took place but but
there were massive domains of
devastation and in those countries that
you know will take hundreds of years to
fix so anyways when scar rules everyone
starves that's a good way of thinking
about it or everyone dies but that's
okay because that's really what he's
after anyway so that works out quite
nicely now back out here in paradise I
mean look at him how pathetic can you
get look at the expression on that
creatures face you know he's he selfs
he's sated like someone who's just eaten
a gallon of ice cream and he's got this
pathetic
self-satisfied naive clueless
unconscious grin on his face which the
animators did a very nice job of
capturing like that's a complicated
expression and you just want to slap him
and that's exactly what should happen
and that's exactly what does happen so
anyways he's out there be an unconscious
dingbat well his society is degenerating
and that's bloody well worth thinking
about because that's an archetypal trope
right it's like things are sinking
around you the question is what are you
doing about it you know are you just
staying in kind of a blithe
unconsciousness because you can get your
next meal are you gonna wake up and do
something about it well that's the call
of the self so now we go back to two
Rafiki here and he knows what's going on
in the kingdom he's a symbol of the self
and he also has some inkling that Simba
is still alive
so so the son of the king is still alive
despite the fact that the land has
become ruled by a tyrant and the son is
absent he's still around somehow and so
in a union from the Union perspective
there isn't much distinction between the
self and the and the and the child the
self is the sum total of all possibility
and the child is possibility itself and
so so let's say you've become an
adolescent you're all cynical right and
everything's falling apart around you
which is the typical state of human
beings right because adolescents are
cynical generally speaking and
everything's falling around falling
apart around them generally speaking and
so what do you have to do in order to to
do something about that well one is you
have to be drawn by the call of wisdom
and the other part is that you have to
rediscover that part of yourself that's
a childlike part that's associated with
the son and associated with that early
you know the early exposure of Simba to
the son you have to find that again and
then trust that some childlike
exploration and a bit of manifestation
of faith might get you to the next place
and so that's what's happening here with
a little you know the baboon and the
tree and the and the drawing so anyways
he knows that Simba is alive now
and so he goes off to find him and
meanwhile Simba and his dopey companions
are out hunting for bugs
you know because he's a lion you know he
should meet bugs for crying out loud but
they're easy and so you see this scene
where Pumbaa goes after this bug and
then another lion shows up and chases
him so she's gonna kill him and eat him
and ha see that's an interesting thing
because one of the things that happens I
suppose you could think about this one
of the things that happens in late
adolescence is that the formation of
male gangs is often broken up by the
proclivity of one or more members of
that gang to get involved in an
individual romantic relationship and so
the idea that the female lion is the
carnivore the female is the carnivore
that will devour the group is exactly
right and so what a girl will do often
if she's in relationship with you know
somebody like a young man or an older
adolescent is she'll try to separate him
from his dopey friends and like no
wonder you know why wouldn't she do that
because he does have dopey friends and
it'd be better for him if he could get
beyond them and so anyways they're
pretty freaked out about this and so
then Simba goes out and has a fight with
this lion to protect his dopey chums and
I'm sure you don't need any explanation
about what that means and they have this
huge fight and neljä who it turns out to
be pins him and so that goes back to the
beginning of the story where when he
first encountered her she pinned him all
the time she's an animal figure right
and now what she does immediately is
shame him so she he's an atom a figure
in part she's an animal figure in part
because she actually does shame him
right so she's the gateway to higher
consciousness she makes him
self-conscious and rightly so but he's
also a she's also a psychological figure
because he imagined that when a young
man is establishing a relationship with
a young woman and he's he's enamored of
her he's falling in love he projects an
idea onto her and that ideal is going to
be partially fulfilled by the
relationship the degree to which is
unspecified and sometimes it'll collapse
completely but he projects an ideal on
to her because otherwise he wouldn't be
attracted to her and then the ideal
judges him and so that makes him feel
all self-conscious and and useful
which is useful because he is useless
and should feel that way and so it's
part of the impetus to growing up so and
of course one of the you need necessity
in order to mature you because to mature
is to take on responsibility and you're
not going to feel that impetus unless
adopting the responsibility has some
sort of payoff and women tend to mate
across an up dominance hierarchy so they
tend to actually like men who are useful
and so if they encounter a man who isn't
useful at all they're gonna that's
exactly what's going to happen they're
gonna not be happy about that in the
least and so and no wonder and I think
the reason for that it's an economic and
a biological reason the reason is is
that women are in the position of having
to take care of infants primarily and an
infant is a very heavy load and so even
a woman who's extraordinarily competent
is going to find herself substantially
limited in her possibilities if she has
an infant and so then she's looking
around for someone who'll pick up part
of the load it's perfectly reasonable
and you're not gonna pick up part of the
load if you're completely useless and so
it's in the woman's best interest not to
have two children roughly speaking so
anyway she pins him and then he's all
resentful about it immediately because
she's calling him on his stupid friends
and the fact that he's out there
gallivanting impulsively in paradise
when there's real problems to be solved
and so look at him he's all resentful
and useless and and you know feeling put
upon and picked upon and you just you
got to slap him again fundamentally and
she's just completely stunned by that
it's like and tells them you know
where's the sim buy used to know right
well he's a little doubtful about the
whole situation there the animators do a
very nice job of this part of the movie
because one of the things you see is
that his eyebrows are always pointing up
in the middle whereas his father's
eyebrows were pointing down in the
middle and so that's the difference
between this which is sort of like
things are happening to me and this
which is more like I'm imposing my will
on things and that's an immature face
and and the animators capture that
brilliantly so here's where she shames
him again she tells him how much she
liked him when he was little and you
know a potential king and
how hurt she is that he's this useless
you know wide-eyed naive impulsive
pleasure-seeking adolescent and she
tells him that she missed him and god
only knows why because look at him again
it's like completely appalling palling
creature and this is when Pumbaa and
Timon sing that song about the fact that
you know their friends doomed because
you know this girl's got him and and
then they switch into another archetypal
scene and so they're falling in love
here and so the paradisal imagery is
really highlighted in the movie and so
they go off and have this like romp
self-reflective romp through this new
paradise and they wrestle around and and
play and then he pins her more or less
and she licks him that's that's not so
good
and this is one of the most brilliant
shots I think that the animators manage
because she's obviously pushing this a
little bit farther than he knows what to
do with and so they're wrestling and he
she licks them and then she lays down
and makes this face which is every
single class I've ever showed this to
all laugh when they see that image and
that's a good example so Freud said that
jokes were a good route into the
unconscious so the question is and this
is an archetypal facial expression and
everyone knows exactly what it means
there's something sexually seductive
about it and something very sexually
seductive about it despite the fact that
it's a lioness and the animators do an
extraordinarily good job of capturing
that and so that has a huge effect on
him while these guys know that hey the
game's up man it's like they know
they're dead whatever attractions they
can offer are paling in comparison to
this so so anyways things don't really
progress past out but you know he gets a
hint of her longing for him what's
waiting for him if he grows up and the
fact that she's completely disappointed
in him because he's so completely
useless and so now he's lounging about
you know like some basement
with cheeto dust all over his chest and
and trying to justify his absolutely
useless life and you know saying that he
doesn't have any responsibility to the
devastated Kingdom and he's out there
where Hakuna Matata you know I can just
do whatever I want and and follow my
impulsive pleasures and she thinks he's
pretty pathetic and the reason for that
is because he is actually pretty
pathetic and she she tells him that you
know she's extraordinarily disappointed
he gets all pouty about it I mean even
here you see when he when he's got kind
of an aggressive look on his face
there's still nothing about it that's
commanding it's petulant right it's like
well now I'm irritated but he's got no
force and and still completely appalling
in this in this particular situation so
she judges him very harshly and leaves
and that makes him think yeah he make
gets all self-conscious because this
female that he admires wants to have
nothing to do with him
and so he's first of all then he thinks
well maybe I'll just hate all women
which is you know pretty pathetic
conclusion and but a very common one and
the next is well maybe there's actually
something wrong with him right which is
a very painful bit of self-reflection so
he he had he notes that there's
something wrong with him and then he
calls out to his father and says look
you said you were always going to be
here for me and you're not and so what's
happening is that he's become aware of
the insufficiency of his current
adolescent value structure and he wants
something beyond it which would be
associated with identification with the
father but he can't he can't find the
father the father's dead it's like when
Pinocchio goes down to the bottom of the
ocean to bring Geppetto up from the
depths right that's the situation that
that Simba finds himself in right now
the father's gone and has to be brought
up from the depths so this is where the
movie takes the the archetypal pathway
of an initiation ceremony so he says he
wants to change now one of the things
Carl Rogers one of the clinicians that
will talk about pointed out was that if
if someone was going to come to
psychotherapy there's some things that
had to happen before they went into
psychotherapy and one thing that had to
happen was that they had to admit that
there was something wrong and they had
to want to change you had to have that
before
went into the psychotherapeutic
situation and what happens here is Simba
is actually he's dropped his arrogance
and he's looking upward kind of like
Geppetto wishing on the star in
Pinocchio he's looking upwards he
looking towards something higher and he
wants to transform himself so he's asked
the question how can I change for the
better and he doesn't get an answer and
then Rafiki shows up so what does that
mean it means that as soon as you know
you're wrong about something as soon as
you admit that you're wrong about
something and you open the door to
potential change that part of you will
respond so and you know this because
think about this you're thinking so you
ask yourself a question because that's
what you do when you're thinking and
then you generate some answers it's like
it's very strange the thinking will
actually work you can actually come up
with answers if you think about
something and so this square this issue
is okay I thought I was real good in my
little impulsive paradise but then it
turns out that I'm just a half-wit and I
noticed that and I want to do something
about so the question is now the
question is has now been posed and what
young would say is the deeper part of
yourself the part that still contains
your undeveloped potential will respond
to that posed question and change the
way that you look at things and change
the way that you act it'll start it'll
start changing things so that you can
tap those parts of yourself that are not
yet developed and you certainly do that
in psychotherapy but you can do that
young said that psychotherapy could be
replaced by a supreme moral effort and
by that he meant was that if you really
wanted things to be better if you wanted
to get your act together and you
admitted that you were insufficient in
your current state and you meditated on
the issue and tried to figure out what
you should do next to make to put
yourself together that you would be able
to find out that there's something in
you that guides the process of
development that's the self that's a
higher its the higher self in some sense
it's the thing that remains constant
across transformations you know because
you're somewhere then you fall apart
then you get somewhere else but there's
something outside of that that's guiding
that process and that's that's also the
self that's what you
would be and you can communicate in some
sense with what you could be and that's
a very strange thing about human beings
anyways Rafiki shows up and Simba is
sitting by the water self reflecting
there's a little pebble that drops into
the pool to attract his attention and up
pops the self and Rafik he's a trickster
he tells him weird jokes and he hits him
with a stick a bunch of times thank God
because someone really needs to and he
he makes some stupid jokes about bananas
and kind of entices Simba into following
him right he lets him know that he has a
secret and he entices Simba into
following him so simha's all of a sudden
become interested in something so if you
ask yourself what the next developmental
stages and you really want to know that
all of a sudden you're going to become
interested in things that might move you
to the next stage and that'll happen
more or less unconsciously so anyways
Rafiki entices him and then runs away
and Simba follows him and well that's
where he reveals himself as a sage and
then he tells Simba to follow him and he
goes underground and this is the
initiation scene right which we talked
about at the beginning of the class this
is the descent into the underworld and
it's a it's a prerequisite to radical
personality transformation so anyways he
goes through this horrifying underground
tunnel system where everything's all
tangled up which is you know if you ever
fall into chaos that everything down
there in chaos is tangled up it's a
tangled mess and he's quite and there's
horrifying music going on in the
background and he goes deeper and deeper
until Rafiki says he finds a pool in the
middle of the chaos a deep pool and
that's another symbol of the self it's
it's the deep unconscious to something
down there that's alive that can be
drawn up to the surface and so Rafiki
shows him the pool and Simba who's quite
terrified at this point looks in it and
the first thing he sees is he only sees
himself he only sees his own reflection
and Rafiki says look deeper now you see
what the animators do here it's very
cool
so there's Simba and there's his
reflection but you see that is already
half is farther and you look at the
difference in the eyebrows and the
so there's a there's a tightness of jaw
and a firmness of face that's starting
to manifest itself there and that means
that he's starting to see the man he
could be beyond the adolescent that's a
good way of thinking about it and then
all of a sudden well they're you know
that's a whole different face right
that's a seriously different face that
everything's going in and that it's like
get out of my way because things are
going to happen around me very
judgmental as well so it's not it's not
naive by any stretch of the imagination
but you know we know as far there's a
good guy and so there's something
archetypal about this and so he sees the
man he could be reflected back to him
and then that's which is that actually
becomes a cosmic event and we switch up
to the sky instead
and so Mufasa manifests himself
basically as a solar deity and he tells
Simba that he's forgotten who he is
which is the son of a king and that he
should remember that and start acting
like it
and that's an archetypal idea so if
you're just a useless adolescent then
you've forgotten who you are and the
consequence of that is that the state is
going to fall around fall apart around
you and you're not going to do anything
to fix it and you're not going to be
good for anything and no one's gonna be
able to rely on you and you're gonna be
all whiny and resentful and then after
that it even gets worse and so that's
basically what Mufasa tells him and so
Simba is like blown away by this vision
right because he sees what he could be
and also what he's not which is pretty
damn horrifying so anyways the storm so
to speak clears and Rafiki comes up and
and Simba's a lot more thoughtful and
not quite as whiny and resentful anymore
and Rafiki leaves and so Simba now knows
what he's supposed to do he's supposed
to stop being useless and take on the
moral requirements of setting the
Kingdom straight and so he runs back
across the desert there's all sorts of
impressive music happening and then he
comes back to his kingdom and it's not
looking so good and that's the
consequence of his his abandonment of it
that's a big
part of it so now it's dead but also his
abandonment of it - nothing but
malevolence and chaos and so he's pretty
taken aback and what's happened and that
he exaggerates his guilt or it should
anyways and neljä shows up and and they
decide they're gonna do something about
this so in the meantime
Simba's mother is complaining about the
fact that there's no food in the kingdom
anymore and that they've gone as far as
they can and Skaar doesn't want to hear
this so he he attacks her and Simba
decides to go to war and so this is
where he wakes up and he's willing to
encounter the shadow at this point and
so he confronts scar and scars very
concerned about this because actually
Simba is looking pretty impressive now
and he thought he was dead besides and
so he tries to use treachery and whiny
Nessun and subordination to excuse
himself but he's planning to overthrow
Simba nonetheless to resist him so he
tells scar to leave he's going to banish
him to the nether regions outside of the
kingdom like scar did to him and scar
basically refuses and then a storm
gathers right and lights the Deadwood
around the rock on fire so we have
another kind of descent into hell seen
here very common in Disney movies this
this this notion of the hero fighting
the evil force on the edge of something
that's burning it's quite a common motif
you see it in Sleeping Beauty for
example so they have a big war and scar
ends up putting Simba in the same
position that Mufasa was in and then he
whispers to him that he killed his
father so Simba has been thinking all
along that it was only his fault and it
is sort of his fault but he didn't know
that there was a more archetypal theme
playing out in the background which is
that societies are always endangered by
malevolence always and that's
independent to some degree of Simba's
decisions and his and his lack thereof
anyways scar tells him because he thinks
he's won and that energizes Simba to
have this sort of final battle he leaps
out from the
and they have a big fight and he pins
him basically and the female lioness has
come to his aid and Simba tells him that
again that he has to leave and so they
have a big fight that's a particularly
good bit of animation so there's real
demonic aspect to scar they're sort of
King of Hell imagery and but he loses
and then ha he blames his minions he
blames the hyenas for everything
terrible this happening forgetting that
they can hear him and then he falls off
the cliff and the hyenas go in and
finish him off
so it's pretty brutal ending for poor
old scar eaten by his own minions and
then scars dead and Simba has one and so
the rains come immediately and so what
does that mean well it means that when
proper order is restored in a kingdom
then everything starts to flourish again
and so the rains come and then while
it's raining Simba climbs up to the top
of the rock and now he's completely
mature right that the facial the
pathetic facial expression disappears
entirely knee straightens himself up
because now he's full of serotonin after
having defeated good old scar and all
the lionesses are roaring and he climbs
up Pride Rock and they roar at him which
is good they're tough and he's tough and
they showing their teeth it's it's not
it's not a society of naive and harmless
creatures it's it's something that's got
some bite and the rains come and then
the next thing you see is the
restoration of the kingdom and so
basically that what that means is that
if the individual is willing to confront
their own shadow and then to take on the
malevolent forces that continually
undermine society then harmony can be
restored and everyone can do well and so
then we have a return to the beginning
right and so Simba and nella are now a
couple along with Pumbaa and Timon and
they have a baby and Rafiki shows up and
does the same thing you know he's gonna
present the baby to the Sun and have all
the animals bow again and and that's the
end of the movie so that's all packed
that's all packed into an archetypal
tale and and so one of the things that
young would point out is that you all
understood this right while you were
watching it because otherwise at some
level all these things made sense they
all cohered and the narrative appeared
to be an appropriate narrative even when
you're a little kid it because it
strikes a chord inside you and well that
chord the thing that it strikes inside
you that's the archetype because if
there wasn't something inside of you so
to speak that this could communicate
with and it would fall on deaf ears and
it speaks to the part of you that's most
particularly human and it's a story of
the development of the sovereign
individual that's that's the right way
to think about it's a hero archetype
that's another way of thinking about it
and people are going to get that story
one way or another and now and then a
piece of public art comes along like
this that does a good job of
encapsulating and it captures everyone's
imagination and so that's why you've all
seen it and why I presume you all
enjoyed it when you were kids and maybe
still enjoy it now so well that was
actually faster than I thought it would
be today so this is what I'm gonna do
we've got 20 minutes so why don't you
think for a minute or two and I'll take
some questions which I don't often do
but and they can be any questions about
anything we've covered in class so take
a minute and yes
- movie
you feel like you know the character but
it's not exactly that character like
become so - you know can
like it feels like you know for a wise
old man
archetype yeah yeah well there's not
much difference between Gandalf and
who's the wizard in Harry Potter
Dumbledore they could be the same guy
it's right right and so well that that
is precisely the indication of the
existence of an archetype it's like an a
movie one time a student asked me well
if if there are these archetypes why
don't we just tell the archetype over
and over why do we need fiction for
example which is like a bridge if
there's individuals here and the
archetype is up here you know at a high
level of abstraction fiction sort of
fills the gap between them and so what
you want is a story that's archetypal so
that you understand its basic structure
but you want enough variation and
specificity so that it's new and
interesting and also applicable to you
so you have to humanize the archetype to
some degree otherwise it's so abstract
you can't you can't relate to it and and
good stories really do that they bridge
the gap and some of them are more
personal and less archetypal but if
they're completely non archetypal
there's nothing about them that captures
you it doesn't have any force and then
if it's two archetypal well it gets to
be too abstract and you can't relate to
it so good fiction writers and and good
purveyors of dramatic entertainment we
think about it as entertainment are
really good at occupying that middle
position so yeah and they reveal the
archetype through the individual that's
one way of thinking about it and and
that keeps it fresh and you know one of
the things that you pointed out to was
that you're you're going to be
manifesting archetypal patterns of
behavior in your life whether you know
it or not
even when you do something like fall in
love because that's going to be a very
particular experience for you but it's
also a very common experience at the
same time right and and romance is older
than people that's one way of looking
about looking at it I mean because sex
is older than human beings and so you're
in the grip of something that's really
ancient but at the same time it's really
personal and so a good novelist or a
writer of fiction is able to capture
both the personal element of that to
show show the transpersonal within the
personal and so and in some sense your
destiny property
study from a union perspective is to
consciously express an archetype and so
be the archetype there's a bunch of them
but one of them would be the archetype
of the hero and you're supposed to
manifest that in the conditions of your
own life so that makes the archetype
real in the conditions of your own life
and Jung would also say that when you're
doing that your experience will manifest
itself as meaningful and so it's because
in some sense you're acting in
accordance with your deepest instincts
technically speaking right you're you're
acting out what it means to be human in
the world and you're gonna find that
meaningful so yes
like
like I just like because it's mine
process from life
like happy but is like appreciating to
help so like
you know like love and subsidies
okay so the question is about the
relationship between the shadow and the
okay so the first thing you have to
understand with regards to trying to
come to terms with the conception of the
shadow is to understand the idea of
persona and persona is the you that you
present when you want people to accept
and like you often like let's say that
you go to a party and you're trying to
impress the people that are there and
you're trying to get them to like you
and so you maybe get jabbed out a little
bit and you laugh and you know you're
you go along with everyone so that they
like you and then you go home and you're
bitterly resentful about the way that
you were put down at this party and
that's going to make all sorts of
aggressive I wish I could have said it's
gonna make all sorts of aggressive and
vengeful thoughts sort of flashed
through your imagination well the first
part of the problem is that you were too
much persona right you sacrificed
yourself in some sense at the party so
that people would like you and in the
second part you're refusing to admit to
the existence of those elements of you
that would have actually protected you
from doing that so let's say you go home
and you're all bitter and resentful and
you have fantasies of revenge I mean
that reveals to you the shadow part of
you that's aggressive and the thing is
you actually need that because if you
would have integrated that more
successfully into your personality when
you went to the party you wouldn't have
had lit you wouldn't have had to let
people put you down to get them to like
you you know instead of having a face
like this which says I'll take anything
that's coming my way you know you have a
face and a stance that's more determined
and assertive and if you manifest that
properly people aren't gonna mess with
you to begin with
but you know you may have already
adopted a morality that says well I have
to be likeable and I shouldn't do
anything that causes any conflict and I
shouldn't ever you know hurt anybody's
feelings and so you're just to present
yourself as a punching bag and you think
that that makes you a good person but it
doesn't and there's no integration of
the shadow in that situation
so you see that at the end of the movie
we know I mentioned this when Simba
climbs up the rock to take control of it
all the female lionesses bare their
teeth and he roars it's like that
aggressiveness is integrated into him
and so resentment is a really good
emotion for making contact with the
shadow side because if you're resentful
about something it basically reveals two
things it either means that you're
immature and you should stop whining and
get on with things you know someone's
ass this often happens with adolescents
who are asked say by their mother to
clean up the room they get all resentful
about it it's like shut up and clean up
your room you know it's not that much to
ask or so that can be a gateway into the
observation of your own immaturity or
it's possible that you're resentful
because people really have been poking
at you too much and taking and and
taking shots at you and oppressing you
but what that means is that you've got
some things to say that you haven't been
willing to say or don't know how to say
right you can't stand up for yourself
properly and in order to do that you
have to grow some teeth and be willing
to use them and again that's something
that might violate your morality because
you might say well I shouldn't be able
to bite people and the thing is yes you
should be able to bite people hard and
if you're able to bite them then
generally you don't have to but they
need to know that you can because
otherwise especially people who are
badly socialized they'll just keep
encroaching on you and encroaching on
you and encroaching on you and
encroaching on you until you you put up
a wall like someone who's really well
put together won't do that you know
because they're sophisticated but if you
run into people who only have boundaries
because other people impose them on them
and you won't do it you're gonna be the
bullied one in the office for example
you're not gonna get a raise people
aren't gonna credit you with your own
work other people are gonna take credit
for it you know and you're gonna go home
angry because you're doing your best and
you're trying to get along with everyone
and nothing ever goes your way well it's
because you're a pushover and you think
that's good because you confuse
harmlessness with with with
reality it's it's about it's not right
just because you can't do any damage
doesn't mean your morale just means your
you don't have the capability for mayhem
and that makes you a pushover I mean the
yogya stuff is very very dark you know
it's very dark because his notion of
what constitutes a moral human being is
much different from the typical view he
really thinks you get that horrible side
of yourself integrated so it's up there
where you can use it because otherwise
you're you're dangerous you can't say no
to people and you'll go along with the
crowd and then if the crowd does
something particularly pathological
which it's liable to do you won't be
able to resist it you won't have the
strength of character and so then you'll
fall prey to to crowd pathology and
it'll be because you're too agreeable
with a you know with a shadow resentful
side that the crowd and its murderous
intent is gonna act out so yes yes so
the question is the relationship between
archetype archetypes and the idea of
memes well
oh yeah that's a complicated one so
Richard Dawkins was the guy who
originated the idea of meme and his
notion was that you could produce an
idea or a set of ideas that had the
capacity to propagate across minds for
whatever reason it was catchy let's say
like a like a song that gets stuck in
your head you know it and that those he
called those memes which was sort of a
play on the idea of genes so there are
these stable sets of ideas that can be
transferred across minds well I've often
thought when I was reading Dawkins that
if he would have kept thinking he would
have turned into Carl Jung because an
archetype is a meme but it's a really
really really deep meme so you can
imagine that an idea has been sold
around for so long and that people have
acted out for so long that it's actually
become part of the landscape that does
the selection so think about it this way
so it's more or less a truism that if
you take a male dominance hierarchy the
probability that the men at the top of
the hierarchy will leave offspring is
much higher than the probability that
the men at the bottom will leave
offspring and it's true in many many
species now there's a much higher
probability of the average female
leaving offspring than the average man
so so now then imagine that there's
characteristics that push a man up a
dominance hierarchy okay and then
imagine that there are characteristics
that push a man up a set of dominance
hierarchies so that each dominance
hierarchy has something in common with
all of the others it's sort of like the
idea of a good player of a game being a
good sport across games so then imagine
that the idea of the successful male
starts to become encapsulated in in in
biology because this species is going to
the male part of the species at least is
going to be adapting to the selection
pressures placed on the male by the male
dominance hierarchy so what happens is
you have a competition between men the
men that win the competition find
partners in mate
so the the male is going to start to
adapt to the fact of the selection
that's implemented by the dominance
hierarchy then you can imagine that
that's going to take case take place
across dominance hierarchies because
this is happening in many many
situations spread across time and so
then the idea of how the proper man
should act starts to become incorporated
in the biology and also in the
expectations of the society and then
that starts to loop so as the
expectations become clearer and clearer
the notion of what it constitutes
success becomes clearer and clearer as
well and the two things get tangled
together now and I think you can see
that a manifestation of that whenever
you go watch a movie because you
immediately identify the hero and you
identify with them it's like he's
the person that your mythological
imagination grasps on to and you play
that out using your body as a
representational platform when you watch
the movie and so maybe you admire the
hero if he's a successful hero you do
well that admiration is the
manifestation of the instinct that
drives you towards that kind of behavior
and not only can you manifest it in
which case you're likely to feel good
about yourself because you know that
sometimes you can feel good about
yourself and sometimes not but you're
also going to be able to recognize it
when you see it in the world and that's
going to manifest itself in admiration
and admiration is the proclivity to
imitate so the meme can be soul so you
can imagine dominance hierarchies are
very very old they're like 300 million
years old
they've been around a very long time and
the idea that we have an image of what
it takes to climb the dominant targets
it's more or less self-evident because
that's the landscape that selected us
and at the same time you know the the
archetype the pattern that propagates
you up the dominant arc is also the same
pattern that makes you attractive to
women they're the same thing
so and of course that's a massively
powerful selection mechanism and sexual
selection has really shaped human beings
it's turned us into what we are and
that's an interesting thing too because
you know this is one of the things that
really bothers me about the emphasis of
evolutionary scientists on randomness
it's like the the general mutation
generation process is random or quasi
random we don't know that for sure
because there is evidence now that you
can inherit acquired characteristics and
that was nobody thought that was
possible 20 years ago so things are have
taken a very weird twist in the
Darwinian world but for the sake of
argument we could say that the mutation
process is random but the selection
process isn't random it's not even close
to random ever since creatures have been
able to evaluate one another the
selection process hasn't been random and
so basically we're selected by you could
say by the manifestation of
mind in the world unless you believe
that women for example exercise no
conscious choice in their made selection
which seems completely absurd first of
all men consciously choose who's going
to lead them at least in part you know
who's going to succeed in a hierarchy
and women consciously choose their
sexual partners so the idea that the
selection process that the evolutionary
process is random is it's an absurd
proposition sexual selection makes it
non-random and Darwin knew that he
emphasized sexual selection a lot but
modern biologists since the time of
Darwin except for the last about twenty
years down played the role of sexual
selection and I think the reason for
that is that it brings mind into the
evolutionary process in a way that they
don't like and no wonder it's
complicated you know it's like to some
degree we're consciously directing our
own evolution at least through the
mechanism of selection so
yes yes well Dawkins just thought of
memes is something that weren't he never
thought about them is something that
could last long enough to play a role in
selection itself you know he thought
about the Moroz parasitical cognitive
entities I would say that just sort of
floated on the surface of the mental
landscape he never he never grappled
with the idea that a meme could be
something that could last for hundreds
of millions of years roughly speaking so
we got time for one more question if
anybody has yes yes from a political
perspective like if you divide people by
their political affiliation it looks
like liberal men are the most unhappy
they're higher in neuroticism
I think the openness probably
contributes to it as well but we don't
and also possibly the low
conscientiousness when my graduate
students come in or one of the many ways
we're gonna talk about this in some
detail because she's going to tell you
because we've also looked at the
personality predictors of political
correctness which is extraordinarily
interesting as well because it doesn't
really seem to fall exactly on the
liberal conservative continuum so we'll
talk more about that when we get into
the Big Five part of the course okay
good we'll see you on Thursday when
we're going to do a speed review of
Freud